as you all know according to president's
statement this morning last night
america delivered justice to the leader
of isis and struck a serious blow uh to
the terrorist group
our entire nation is grateful for the
patriotism of our military
personnel and intelligence community it
was a successful strike strike was a
strong step toward the fight against
isis
but the death of this isis leader does
not mean the death of isis
congress remains ironclad our commitment
to our national security and we will
continue to work closely
with the administration to defeat this
terrorist state and keep america and our
allies safe today we are having
previously scheduled
classified briefing
by the
cabinet officers
at the beginning of that briefing i have
been told that we will have a briefing
from general austin secretary austin
about the strike of last night but
it's so sad because
this leader of the isis
maybe it's what they believe or whatever
but he decided that he would
he would blow himself up and his
children and his family with them as
well
that's what happened last night
this week
it's a very happy week for us because
that completes act is on the floor it's
a momentous one for the future of
america's workers uh and the economy and
the house as the house passes the
competes act ensuring our nation is
preeminent in manufacturing in
innovation and in economic strength it's
about research i want to salute the art
chair of the science space and
technology committee eddie bernice madam
chair eddie bernice johnson for the
great work that she has done largely in
a bipartisan way
i don't know if the votes will reflect
that but the
bills that came out of her committee as
well as some of them which passed on the
floor passed in about strong bipartisan
way
here's
here we get here we have always been a
beacon of excellence
in science and engineering and
innovation in the world and we invested
in education and innovation in the rest
then other countries
copied
our path
and they emerged as well so we have
competition now some of them one the
people's republic of china a country of
concern
is threatens
our ability to be as preeminent as we
want to be the technologies we rely on
today and the technologies on the future
must be made here in america
and this is what is happening in the
biden administration to make us more
self-sufficient with american workers
it's an imperative for america's
security uh and the financial security
of america's workers and our families
that we are self-sufficient
competes meets this challenge and i'm
going to take the time to talk about
competes because it's a very
where is it
this is just this is not the bill this
is just what we sent out about the bill
it's it's very intense it's intensive
competes meets the child first by
investing 52 billion dollars to uh to
support the manufacturer tips chips and
semiconductors
do you know how many chips are in a
electric car
2000
non-electric car 1000 but the absence of
chips is hindering our manufacturing of
cars we need more chips and we need them
to be made in america they are the
lifeblood of modern technology but
increasingly be made abroad again
sometimes in countries of concern
leaving us vulnerable on supply chain
issues
and that makes cost higher and it
contributes to inflation uh we are
bringing production back
so that's 52 billion dollars chips
semiconductors
secondly the chips act invests 45
billion dollars to support manufacture
and acquisition of critical goods or
industrial equipment essential for our
national security and i'm going to read
you this from here and hope that you
would read this this is
it authorizes 45 billion dollars for
grants loans and loan guarantees to
support salich supply chain resilience
and manufacturing but critical goods
industrial equipment as i say in
manufacturing technology
this is how it relates to our economy
and our families supports the
manufacturing or equipment acquisition
of critical goods or industrial
equipment that are essential for the
national security and economic vitality
critical goods
include key components and products for
public health
biological preparedness
information and communications
technologies
energy and transportation sector
industrial base and agricultural
commodities and food product supply
chains
this is
a magnificent piece of work
and i'm very eager uh i'm very proud of
the support it has had as i said in a
bipartisan way i don't know if that
would be in uh in the um
in the votes
so i told you something about that i can
talk more about if you want and uh but
we must continue to reduce our
dependence
on goods made in other countries
especially countries of concern and
bring production back home said one was
the 51 the 53 2 billion for chips second
was
45 billion for com
for the
supply chain
third and this is not about money but
with
the bipartisan bills that are contained
in this we are advancing u.s scientific
research and innovation excellence to
ensure that we lead the technologies of
the future and fourth we're positioning
the u.s interest and values to win on
the world stage holding the people's
republic of china accountable
for using slave labor
which is a human rights issue and hurts
u.s
workers
okay so again more american goods made
here at home lowers cost and strength in
supply chains for american insurers that
america not the people's republic of
china writes the rules of the road for
the 21st century
speaking of the people's republic of
china before i came here and that's why
i'm a few minutes late i was i testified
at and then listened to the testimony
at the
congressional executive commission on
china hearing
tomorrow the olympic games begin in
china
and we were heard from voices of the
oppressed who spoke out on human rights
violations being perpetrated by the host
nation
while we fully support our athletes and
have not called for a boycott by the
athletes
we cannot be silent on human rights in
china call for a diplomatic boycott but
not an athletic one
that's last year called for no official
u.s presence at the games which
president biden has supported other
countries have followed our lead for
example the united kingdom canada
australia belgium denmark estonia latvia
missouri at the balkan
the baltic states
meanwhile is congress uh
i mean it
i wish you could have heard the
testimony it was a live stream perhaps
some of you saw of the witnesses
they were so eloquent and representing
every aspect of human rights violations
including genocide but what's important
to note and how it relates to economic
economy is that
when you talk about the weak arms and
the camps that these people are sent to
and the rest
when we talk about genocide
that would be enough justification to
oppose the what the u prc is doing but
it's not the only reason what it does is
say to american workers you must compete
with slave labor
and they were very eloquent in
presenting
how pervasive the cotton made in the
uygar
camps and the rest is
not only
as a resource to
perhaps u.s manufacturers but others as
well so this is not just a human rights
issue it's an unfair trade
issue as well
again uh we are of course the subject to
hand is the
omnibus bill that rosa de la is
brilliantly taking the lead on
setting us for a strong omnibus to
address critical priorities for the
american people
right now we are
going back and forth with offers between
the democrats and republicans and the
continues
are hoping to reach a deal on a top line
very soon on that i know that's an issue
that you're concerned about because that
relates
to schedule
and speaking of schedule i am very proud
that
on schedule we have
our goal was to reach a thousand uh of
uh infrastructure events where nearly
1300 infrastructure i think it's 1271
infrastructure events
so far
around the country
again about bridges and roads and
and water supply getting the lead out
broadband
uh
issues that relate to safety on our
streets
even some relationship to addressing the
climate crisis as we spread the word of
our victories for the democrats
we remain hard at work to help to pass
bbb
as well as voting rights one connection
between infrastructure and
omnibus is that some of the money
in the
in the um infrastructure bill cannot be
freed up until we pass the omnibus bill
so for these and other reasons to meet
the needs of the people
to show that democrats deliver for the
for the people and we want to do so in a
strong bipartisan way
we have to get that
we're hoping to get that done as soon as
possible in terms of the infrastructure
um excuse me the omnibus bill any
questions
uh speaker a new instagram account
called dear white staffers has been
collecting
trouble
can we if you've got something
extraneous i'm happy to get to it but
let's talk we're trying to keep
government open we're trying to
be preeminent in the world and i'm happy
to come back to that any questions on
what we're doing here jake
what do you have
russia
um
sanctions what is your general thinking
at the moment we are wait uh you have to
build you know a bill in the senate the
menendez bill and then in the house uh
mr meeks's bill from his committee
they're
on a similar path
uh there are those uh somewhat on the
republican side who would like to have
the the uh preemptive have these
sanctions first where i you asked me
where i come down and in keeping with
the guidance from my committee chair mr
meeks the and the administration
uh
i think it's really important for us to
use the sanctions if the russians strike
it is important because we it's where
leverage is at maximum if they do this
then we strike it is where also most of
our our allies are on this and we that
is a very important part of this how we
work jointly on it and that is why um
that is why
i support
using sanctions if they invaded
well the committee i think they have to
be very
much uh more forceful than they have
been because they we're talking about
an invasion of a country uh we're
talking about nato
uh being
nato countries
being at risk if the russians
succeed
in ukraine so this is a this is deadly
serious
so they have to feel the pain and that
has to be felt right up to the richest
man in the world vladimir putin nobody
knows what he's going to do except him
and that's why we have to be prepared
for whatever that may be
but i do think that they have to be
strong enough to be effective
they have to be done after and if they
invade
and
have to be done
in compliance with our allies working
together yeah
the january 6th committee we know that
their scope keeps getting bigger we know
they're looking at timelines leading up
to the attack where people were what
they were doing
i wonder have you provided any kind of
testimony or documents to the community
no no i keep as far away from the
committee as possible if they ask me i
would but i don't
i was on the podium and then i was swept
away do you expect to be asked about
things like that i have no idea or
evacuation procedure i had no idea i
hadn't i i know about what they do the
way you do in the public domain
we authorize them we
give them the resources they need to do
what they do but that is the work of the
committee
yes ma'am
on that legislation by congress once
it's done and when it's ready yeah you
plan to fast track that bring it
straight to the house school or possibly
skipping markup and then i just wonder
if you can respond we heard some
comments from senator joe manchin this
week saying that bill back better is
dead i know in your previous press
conference you referenced possibly that
it could be renamed or rebranded
but you got a couple different questions
there before you go on to a third let me
address the first two
first the uh well we're going to be
briefed
mr makes will be presiding on our side
uh at the briefing ukraine briefing and
what he is we want to move quickly with
these now they'll be up to the chairman
as to the process and the rest but um
but we we want to be as close to the
senate bill as possible so there's no
delay in getting something to the
president's desk
the second part is that i'm never giving
up on bbb now there's so much in there
that is really important in terms of
child tax credit in terms of
family
health care for families that is to say
not just children but
seniors or siblings with disabilities
and the rest
with universal pre-k
this is
so
it's about lowering cost for the
american people lowering the cost of
health care lowering the cost of child
care along the cost of family care and
cost of education at the
pre-k
uh level and
we have to we must get something done
and of course a very important part of
it is what we're doing about the climate
crisis and and i there are plenty of
things in there when i think that we can
find
common ground uh
so i'm not giving up on it
that's
incidental i mean what's important is
what's in the legislation lowers cost
increases pay
and is completely paid for so one other
thing about it is when we talk about
inflation people say oh you're spending
money on this or that this is completely
paid for not only is it paid for it will
in fact
reduce the national debt because it is
um
we you know we raised so much more money
because we thought we were going to do
so much
so much more so i'm very um
we cannot abandon it we must
we must proceed now yes ma'am
coming up shortly but do you have any
knowledge or concern about reports that
russia could create some type of false
pretext to attack it appears u.s
officials may have evidence for that
but i don't want
you know we'll get our classified
briefing and be more up-to-date on it
but the fact is that our troops amassed
at the uh uh eastern uh
border of ukraine uh what
whether it is imminent or not
we have to be ready for it whenever it
is
and again we have um
concerns that we share with other nato
with other nato countries
in the region
so we'll have to be prepared nobody's
what we hear is no one but
the man himself knows whether what he's
going to do
and uh and i'm very pleased that the
our secretary of state has engaged in
diplomacy because diplomacy deterrence
is what we want to see succeed
diplomacy deterrence uh the secretary
secretary blinken has been
forceful in that engagement
but that engagement also
you in order to be good peacemakers you
have to show that you can be a good
fighter i always say
uh the um
so we'll see but uh
in terms of their intention uh i have
nothing to share with you about the
intelligence on that here
we go
afghanistan resolution
first are you concerned about
the military moving these troops even
though they're not going to have boots
on the ground and what the concerns are
about members of your caucus who said we
just repealed these au mounts
what is congress's role
as it pertains to war powers to be
involved in
moving these troops forward in europe
well you you have a
multifaceted
question but the fact is we have to do a
new iu method authorization for the use
of military force what is there is still
old and we have to do it it's
challenging because you have to decide
on many things the authorization for
what
what is the uh what is the purpose what
is the scope what is the timetable and
what is the geography
and that's why
it has
we haven't had another one since because
we
have to come to agreement on that would
it pertain to something like this what
we're seeing right now to moving those
troops i don't think so
why not
well we could put because because they
they they're
no i don't think it does i don't think
we need an emf for that in terms of
the scope
and the uh
the threat that is there
you
you don't have nor do i a definition of
what the purpose of those troops there
are they are a confidence builder for
our our allies in the region uh and they
are
if
if
need be for where we go next we'll make
some judgment but right now just to move
those troops now your question
attempts to unionize here in congress
well we're just unionized at the d
triple c and i supported that yeah i
supported that
so i'm wondering in the in the bill the
complete fact that actually uh
it tries to increase cooperation with
china to address climate change so i'm
just wondering how can um how can you
ensure that while increasing that
cooperation you can also be sure that
the chinese communist party is taking
the sanctions and xinjiang seriously and
not trying to get around those sanctions
well we are very serious about the uh
the uygar legislation that we passed in
a bipartisan way
senator rubio
and chris smith on the republican side
senate and house
jim mcgovern congresswoman wexton
senator merkley and others this has been
bipartisan and bicameral so nobody
should be
misunderstand how serious we are about
that i
would when we pass the appropriations
bill we'll have the funding to fund our
follow-up on checking on what country
companies might be using products coming
from prison labor camps making our
workers compete with prison labor
the chinese we certainly i look i've
take second place to no one in this
congress and my criticism of china for
over 30 years since tiananmen square my
first when i first came to congress and
i fought them every step of the way on
trade issues on human rights issues and
on proliferation of weapons
uh weaponry and delivery systems
over the years
i also have worked with them
on issues that relate to climate i've
been to china on that very subject where
we have seen what they have doing they
deserve credit for many of things they
were doing in terms of of um
of climate but they still remain a major
emitter as do we and we all have to do
better but we have made our decisions
they um
it's in their interest
it's in their interest because they have
a pollution problem that is a health
issue there and that becomes a political
issue as well as an economic issue so
again we cannot say because we hope you
we hope you do something on um
climate that we can ignore the fact that
you're committing genocide of a
population in your country that's just
not going to happen and i said and i'll
close with this and that is
that um
i've said it all the time in fact i've
said it in dharam salah with his
holiness the dalai lama
standing right next to me if we ignore
human rights abuses in china because of
commercial interest
then we lose all moral authority to talk
about human rights any place in the
world
what does it
what does it profit a person or a
country
to gain commercially and suffer the loss
of its soul we cannot do that
so again let's have a balance in all of
it recognize we share this planet
that we hope that we can work together
with them diplomatically on climate
where we have
common ground
but we will not and cannot
they they say the chinese they say um
and torturers generally say
the most
sinister form of torture to a prisoner
of conscience is that they say to them
nobody cares they don't even remember
you they don't even know you're in jail
or why so why don't you just give it up
well we do everything we can to make
sure that they know that we are
publicizing these names as we did
this morning once again not only us but
the witnesses who came reading the names
of others
so again what the chinese are doing
to these people and their families if
their families for example testify that
their loved one is being
uh
imprisoned endlessly for practically
nothing
uh
that's an act of cowardice on the part
of the chinese government to take it out
on
children and families and and these
regards you know they send these people
to these camps and then they take their
children
i mean this is
this is
diabolical
it's diabolical so again for over 30
years i've been making that fight but
that doesn't mean that we shouldn't be
we work together on the uh the iran
nuclear
agreement we worked we can work together
on climate issues we can try to find
common ground where we can
but that does not negate our commitment
to our values thank you all very much
thank you thank you
what happened
don't break my heart
nobody expected us
did you want a bengals 49er super bowl
again
i was there i was there in miami with my
family my kids and all they were little
then it was a long time ago
so we'll see how it goes of course
thanks